[Musica]
ciao a tutti noi siamo raysse momo momo
e raissa raissa e momo
in ogni caso siamo una coppia e 2
content creator da circa un anno
pubblichiamo contenuti sui social che
possano inviare un messaggio positivo un
messaggio di tolleranza inclusività e in
ogni caso il nostro nome di battaglia e
raissa e momo
ora sì ma inizialmente con l'ufficiale
doveva essere un altro avremmo dovuto
chiamarci pizza kebab sì poi per
questioni di business
abbiamo rinunciato è questione di
business erano che postare contenuti sui
social con un profilo che avesse nel
nome la parola kebab per chi ci stava
intorno suonava un po troppo arabo che
il kebab e turco e turchi non sono arabi
e su queste ragione ma in ogni caso ci
siamo tolti il problema perché race e
momo è meglio suona meglio e soprattutto
il tuo nome prima del mio e vorrei dire
che è stata solo una scelta da gentleman
ma non è così dovete sapere che postare
prima il nome della parte femminile
della coppia un'ottima strategia per
evitare problemi soprattutto se sei un
immigrato marocchino e ti chiami
mohammed problemi come a c'è il primo
uomo di lei sa perché sei musulmano è
per te le donne e valgono meno
mi piacerebbe dirti che non sarebbe
successo ma mentirei
perché vedete noi fin dall'inizio
abbiamo iniziato quello che a me piace
chiamare una relazione di piazza nel
senso che eravamo io e lui più i
consigli pareri e opinioni non richieste
di tutte le persone che ci stavano
intorno e infatti questo può essere un
esempio
già solo per scegliere i nomi dei nostri
canali social la scelta è stata quasi di
gruppo
non perché noi ascoltassimo per forza le
opinioni degli altri ma a volte basta
anche solo sentirle per essere
minimamente condizionati infatti se
dovessi descrivere la nostra situazione
con un'immagine la descriverei come io e
lui al centro di una piazza circondata
da palazzi altissimi pieni di finestre e
dietro ogni finestra qualcuno che sposta
la tenda e guarda un po come quando la
sera torni a casa e ti metti a
chiacchierare sotto casa e c'è la vicina
del terzo piano che spia ecco questo era
più o meno la situazione che detta così
vicino a parte ovviamente sembra un po
urbanistico di grillo ferro un filosofo
che tra le altre teorie sosteneva anche
le finestre
proprio le finestre e quelle che abbiamo
tutti in casa avessero una posizione
privilegiata e questo è anche facile da
immaginare perché tu dalla finestra puoi
guardare le persone dall'alto senza
dover necessariamente interagire con
loro può essere vare il ritmo della
città senza entrare nel caos
tutto questo però è altrettanto
limitante e la mia vicina del terzo
piano lo sa bene perché lei vorrebbe
sentire quello che dico ma non riesce
allo stesso modo da dietro la finestra
arrivano i suoni ma sono votati e
inoltre puoi stare ad osservare ma non
riuscirai mai a guardare oltre quello
che vedi questa immagine calza a
pennello con la nostra relazione
ma penso che realtà sia estendibile un
po tutti noi perché tutti a turno nella
vita siamo sia dietro la finestra che in
piazza ad essere osservati perché le
finestre nella vita sono i pregiudizi
sono gli strumenti attraverso i quali
noi guardiamo quello che pensiamo di
conoscere lo giudichiamo ma senza
vederlo realmente per quel che è
ma se ci limita così tanto perché
continuiamo a guardare da questa
finestra perché come dicevi prima ha una
posizione privilegiata e se ci pensiamo
ci dà anche un senso di protezione
protezione da qualcosa che li in mezzo
alla piazza ma che non capiamo perché
diverso da noi è successo più volte
durante la nostra relazione che
dovessimo scontrarci con pensieri poco
gradevoli commenti inopportuni e
soprattutto con stereotipi completamente
lontani da ciò che era effettivamente la
realtà lottavamo che alcuni aspetti
della nostra relazione creassero più
disagio a chi osservava che a noi che li
vivevamo e qui mi viene in mente
un'immagine meravigliosa eravamo
all'inizio della nostra relazione
le nostre famiglie erano ancora un po
titubanti sulla nostra storia d'amore
con titubanti intendo terrorizzate noi
comunque decidiamo di partire fare tre
giorni a parigi
quei tre giorni tira un vento
incredibile io ero senza cappello la
prima cosa che mi viene in mente di fare
è prendere una sciarpa e avvolgere mela
intorno alla testa e poi continuo la
visita della città facendo foto e video
mi sfugge un piccolo particolare cioè la
leggera islamofobia
la mia famiglia aveva prima di conoscere
uomo quindi immediatamente quello che
per me era il gesto di coprirsi le
orecchie dal freddo per loro era
diventato qualcosa di estremamente
preoccupante questo perché perché a
parigi non ero con paolo ma ero con
mohamed e mi ricordo che per evitare
colpi al cuore
a questi tuoi video nè subito seguito 1
miglio in cui spiegavo in modo scherzoso
a tua madre che con la tua scelta di
abbigliamento io non c'entravo
assolutamente nulla perciò la domanda
sorge spontanea perché la diversità tra
virgolette pesa di più a chi la vede che
a chi la vive io m'ammo viviamo la
nostra quotidianità con differenze
culturali religiose caratteriali abbiamo
anche i riferimenti nell'infanzia con i
quali siamo cresciuti totalmente diversi
eppure questo non ci crea disagio anzi
ci arricchisce io non vivo le mie
giornate pensando che le cinque
preghiere al giorno di momo siano un
limite per la mia vita
lui non vive le sue giornate pensando
che il mio mezzo bicchiere di vino del
pranzo siano un limite per la sua
neanche ci facciamo caso se non
attraverso gli altri che ci ricordano
che queste nostre differenze potrebbero
crearci problemi
perciò perché pesa agli altri penso che
la risposta ruota intorno al concetto di
paura
il pregiudizio in sé è carico di paura
perché nasce quando non conosciamo
qualcosa che sia un paese e una cultura
una religione e cerchiamo pur non
conoscendola di interpretarla la
semplifichiamo estendendo delle
osservazioni che abbiamo fatto su un
piccolo gruppo che più o meno
rappresenta quella diversità a tutto il
gruppo e in questo modo la stereotipi
diamo e si dice stereotipi dare
l'abbiamo cercato su tre cani perché il
fatto che io sia musulmano non implica
che la mia compagna debba
necessariamente convertirsi di dos armi
già ber
eppure ogni persona che abbiamo
incontrato che conosciamo finisce sempre
per fare la stessa domanda ma quindi
adesso devi mettere il velo
questo succede perché probabilmente
nello stereotipo collettivo
l'uomo musulmano è sempre accompagnato
da una donna con il velo o kidon e qui
fare molta attenzione a non fare il
furbo e limite proprio qui che ci
perdiamo le mille facce di uno stesso
fenomeno perché ne siamo distanti e
proprio perché ne siamo distanti in
qualche modo lo ignoriamo e ignoranza
non è per forza un insulto a volte
semplicemente un dato di fatto è un non
conoscere
cosa ad esempio raissa la scoperta
l'anno scorso che la capitale del
marocco non è marrakech ma e rabat e
l'ha scoperto perché quando l'ho
invitata a passare qualche giorno con la
mia famiglia a rabat ha appunto pensava
stessi parlando di un piccolo paesino di
30 abitanti in mezzo al deserto e questo
le faceva paura
poi per fortuna scoperto che realtà una
grande città con i centri commerciali
addirittura alle scale mobili
perciò questo vetro di pregiudizi ci
ostacola nel fare tantissime cose nel
conoscere culture persone ci ostacola
nel vivere con fiducia le nostre
differenze e nella peggiore delle
ipotesi a volte ostacola l'amore e penso
che io uomo siamo l'esempio lampante di
quanto sia realmente fondamentale
smetterla di guardare da dietro queste
finestre e riuscirci oggi ancora più
semplice perché non è necessario
prendere un aereo volare in marocco per
scoprire che non si scambiano le donne
con i cammelli
ma basta sbloccare un telefono ad essere
semplicemente curiosi c'è un però ed è
quello che abbiamo notato lavorando sui
social cercando di distruggere alcuni di
questi stereotipi
quello che più ci preoccupa è che per
quanto accedere alla conoscenza sia
facile eliminare un pregiudizio
costruito giorno dopo giorno nella
quotidianità di una persona è davvero
difficile come mi diceva mio padre
emigrato al nord dalla puglia negli anni
60 se c'era un meridionale che faceva
qualcosa bene era quello diverso dagli
altri era quello bravo se c'ero
meridionale che faceva qualcosa di male
era perché erano tutti così ecco la
difficoltà è proprio questa sradicare un
intero insieme di stereotipi creati su
un'intera comunità
una difficoltà che ci tramandiamo di
generazione in generazione
per questo se ci dobbiamo immaginare il
mondo di domani
noi non ce lo vogliamo immaginare come
un esercito di moralisti pronto a
distruggere finestre invece lo vogliamo
immaginare come un insieme di persone
pronte a conoscersi per evitare di
guardarsi da dietro queste finestre
perciò non sarebbe meglio aiutare le
generazioni future non ad abbattere i
pregiudizi ma smettere di crearne grazie
[Applauso]